uh let's uh invite into the program now
former Arkansas Governor Mike Huckabee
Fox News contributor Joe Concha on set
here uh tonight's big breaking news the
illegal immigrant Texas mass shooter is
now in custody tonight law enforcement
officials now uh will be giving details
any moment when we get them we'll bring
them to you Joe I want to look at this
from the media angle
um all the liberal networks seem to want
to ignore the fact that this involved an
illegal immigrant that had left the
country had been deported five times
came back five times he killed five
innocent people in Cold Blood including
an eight-year-old child
they wanted to focus more on the making
this a gun issue you've been watching
the coverage why do they want to just
completely ignore what is the law of the
land now Joe Biden may not agree with
the law but he's the president he has
the the bully pulpit of the presidency
he can make the case try and change laws
but he doesn't get to pick and choose
which laws he wants to enforce and which
he will not enforce precisely and let's
say you made the suspect a white Texan
guy who lives here in the country and he
happened to wear a red hat and he
carried out this execution including of
a I have a seven and a nine-year-old
you've met them uh and the fact that
this kind of got brushed under the
carpet right I just looked at the two
networks uh that our cable news networks
they call themselves capable of those
networks by the way and they're fake
news yes well it that that's the that's
the term certainly and uh they're not
talking about this this should be a
breaking story this network on your show
we've blown out all commercials because
it's that big of a story they're not
talking about it even is it because of
the illegal immigrant aspect of it is
that why precisely and they want open
borders and they have turned a blind eye
to six and a half million people
entering our country illegally now I'm
not against immigration I don't care
where people come from I would like a
background check to know that they don't
have radical associations sure I would
like a health check in the middle of a
pandemic I would like people to show
that they're able to take care of
themselves financially and won't be a
burden on the American taxpayer because
we can't afford it does anyone think
that's uh unreasonable I don't think so
right it sounds pragmatic and we've seen
this movie before do we remember the
name Kate steinley yeah I do San
Francisco young woman walking along the
pier with her dad and gets shot by an
illegal migrant to this country who was
deported how many times five times also
right so these things do not have to
happen and you talked before about this
but it Bears repeating 182 people had
been arrested who are on the FBI Terror
watch list coming into this country
those are the ones that we know about
and remember what happened after 9 11.
we kept going through this whole process
of like how do we not connect the dots
and stop this the dots are right here
and if one or two of those cells carry
this out Sean forget about it you're
talking about now six and a half million
people that have come to this country
illegally that's nine times the
population of Washington DC or Denver
Colorado or Boston Massachusetts imagine
that nine watching considering the
magnitude food of the influx of illegal
immigrants and those people that get
away or got aways as we call them there
is no doubt in my mind that there are
Terror cells in this country because of
Joe Biden's wide open border policy and
one day all of us will wake up to
something that is horrible that was
unexpected because Terror cells are
plotting they're planning they're
scheming these attacks against us and it
all happen in large part because open
borders let me bring in Governor
Huckabee Governor great to see you your
uh your take on all of this sir
I just think I want to quote a very
effective political figure Donald Trump
who said we simply cannot allow people
to pour into the United States
undetected undocumented unchecked and
circumventing the line of people who are
waiting patiently diligently and
lawfully to become immigrants in this
country and I think even Democrats would
agree with that statement but it really
wasn't Donald Trump that was Barack
Obama who said that and I just wish that
some of the Democrats who are talking
about Maga Republicans would know that
the guy who did this brutal execution
shooting of a family including an
eight-year-old for God's sake was no mag
of Republican you know this is not
something that happened because of Maga
Republicans it happened because of a
president who doesn't care what's
happening at the border and that
president is Joe Biden I wish he'd have
listened to the man who used to work for
Barack Obama uh Governor if I may remind
you and this audience that on day one
Joe Biden executive order on immigration
ended any border wall construction it
stopped Donald Trump immigration
enforcement it forced local governments
to include illegals in the census if you
recall it ended the passport restriction
uh from violent uh countries that had
Muslim extremists and have fortified
DACA that was day one this was the plan
from day one this was the executive
order from day one
well it was and and I just hope that AOC
will hurry to the border so she can weep
and talk about how terrible it is I hope
Joe Biden will have a news conference
and maybe he'll fly down and talk to
that murdered families uh relatives and
and comfort them or invite them to them
because he's never been the same
Palestine governor
it's an embarrassing thing and my heart
goes out to these innocent people who
simply wanted a nice peaceful evening
for their child and for that a person
who kept violating the laws of this
country we're going after people who
walked into the capitol using all those
resources instead of arresting people
who did this kind of evil crime near our
nation's border uh Governor we
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else